no one's gonna say you're a okie but no
please hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to escape
the I you okie which apparently is a
Michael Jackson Horrigan I didn't know
about that oh hi I didn't know you're
gonna be staring out at me this is the
full release of the game or at least
this is the steam release of the game I
don't know what's different compared to
the version that I played before but I
do know that it's made by the same
people
someone fact check me on that okay to be
able to use the flashlight first you
need to pick it up alright if this is
what qualifies as a tutorial I think I'm
gonna do just fine in this game well I
didn't pick it up so I guess I didn't
even know ooh
recharge the flashlight now priority
number one
okay the way you make noise and the are
you okey we'll check on you okay so a
similar game as before I still need to
get out of this mansion which I'm in for
some reason and the iuo key is chasing
after me for some reason and I got to
get away from the IU okey so doesn't
kill me for some reason oh well this is
a funkalicious room why are there
monitors in here is this I died you okey
monster is completely blind he won't
react to any light or visual stimuli you
can echo look it was he was it well hell
with his teeth with his teeth what does
that mean with his teeth it's gonna
nibble on me and then I'm gonna you can
avoid him by staying still and holding
your breath by holding the right mouse
button hope you where's the limited
amount of time you can hold your breath
I've discovered I can oh my breath for
up to three minutes so maybe you need to
fact-check about who you're talking to
there never mind I'm sorry developer
then I said anything about you and I
apologize distinctly if you get too
close to the monster he will enter a
rage mode and he will scream and chase
you no matter what
well that's comforting no matter what
you say
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh doh
am i fine what what is that what is that
what is that about
right away is the big block am i dead
tutorial oh that was just that that the
hurry of us are without just curious
piece of paper I've never seen that
piece of paper was terrifying
that was horrible why would you do that
to me oh here we go now for real oh my
god oh my god oh my god okay hang in
corridor and help me he is real
yeah I'm pretty sure scary man is real
yeah I I've kind of picked up on this
whole realness by by playing this before
but not this one oh that's not an actual
interactable game that is just silly
okay so I'm a suit so I'm assuming okay
how did I research f no I've already
forgotten how to recharge
yeah whatever it doesn't matter I'm
gonna die no matter what so it's the
rush
almost like it's out of place you didn't
need to tell me that I already saw the
book and I was already on my way here
now if only I could close that behind me
then I'd be super happy nice nice very
nice old computers very good very nice
okay wiring but it's missing leave Oh
missing a lever could you speak up I can
barely hear you and I'm pretty sure the
people at home can barely hear you
either so please be a little more
considerate of our ears oh man I've run
stupid god I run dumb oh I've never seen
a stupider run cycle also I walk dumb
who walks like this with dog ahead
completely back an arm as far forward as
you can
bobbing and weaving down the hallway
doesn't make any sense well ice don't
look good what is it what the weird
symbols that keep appearing on the
middle of my middle oh yeah well wish I
knew how to
g:q cute it was cute right cute was it
cute what was how do I now remember this
oh I don't need controls it is cute why
isn't it queuing I'm cueing oh I have to
turn it on and then cute oh okay well
that's fine now I know what it is you so
I can't go in these these are no longer
hiding on us which is fine there were a
bit too many last time it made it too
easy to get away from him so I'm hoping
that it actually gonna be difficult
what I think yeah what else would they
be lumps of potatoes lumps of potatoes
specifically in the shape of human
outlines yeah that's probably what it is
this looks like a storage room probably
food those weird bags of potatoes so
anomalous I'm always making people think
I read I see you have a weird walk cycle
to like everything in this world you
know walk the same the only one that
doesn't walk weird is out of the eye you
won't you I do not know what the symbol
[Music]
well if I can convince you at least be
careful I think they already know what
you're up to
they may do something about it so you
must act quickly before they manage to
get away with the plans I won't tell
anyone what you're trying to do but
please I beg you okay so that's the same
message as before I think hello it's
locked
Thanks
what huh open the door
maybe I shouldn't maybe I shouldn't you
know I'm gonna leave that alone last
time I thought that was like my sister's
an addict what are you talking about oh
wow I would not have noticed that good
eye
okay that was perfect
what the hell was that are you gonna
tell me or am I gonna have to find out
for myself
well alright you are uh you're actually
a lot less pretty than you were last
time I I didn't think that you were God
I was like I'm gonna go investigate that
seems like a pretty good thing to do
alright you know it's fine it's all good
it's all good dude dude it's fine also
did I just climb out of a bag alright
you know what screw this whole waiting
around thing I'm just gonna run stupidly
on my way no kaboom this time really
weird okay bizarre no kaboom mmm-hmm one
of the I you okey can get me through
here the I woke II don't even say the
name are you okey oh you okay what am I
seeing what is that the end of the
hallway there
Oh what is that what are you what are
you what are you you never said that
about the flashlight before what are you
what am I looking at is this just a pile
of rocks is it nothing
okay where's
city heating rats is it is that eating
the rats
hey buddy yeah you better stay with me
it's not safe out there
I'd like it away from you ooh how do I
get away from you there's a rat over
here you know what rat you were safe
with me but to be perfectly honest
you're boned and I am NOT gonna stick
around until you die so you just be fine
I think it said it's blind so it cannot
see my flashlight maybe this is not the
time for wit okay that rat apparently
isn't he's not coming for that rat so
I'm guessing that I just have to go
forward here for some reason
oh yeah that's a dead rat that's a dead
rat all right I don't know where he is
he seems to be opening a lot of doors
checking a lot of places eaten a lot of
rats coming over this way didn't closer
by the second didn't way too close to
where I'm Heidi Holden is there anything
here that I needed
is there even a point to coming over
here I thought over in this corner
that'll be something good but apparently
not apparently this guy just wants to be
equip me hi
don't don't don't
leave the clock don't don't stop being
clever yeah I don't like you I don't
like people that think they're clever so
you shush I am the one who clubs stop
talking
oh that son come Pinot the right no wow
wow wow
- it's a whole big bag of stress that is
a big ol that is a super-sized bottle of
stress you are awful why
what this happened oh wait why why would
this be the thing that you've chosen to
do why would you choose to do this
that's a good better decision you just
made wise what the hell just anything no
no oh you can hear the things you're not
hearing things are you stupid
what is it with this guy what do you
think you're doing of course you're not
hearing things you saw the thing is that
the door that I can actually go through
is that permanently blow that's
permanently Luke hey bud stop squeaking
you rat bastard just stop squeaking you
can't get away from the I you okie only
I am the one who can get away so what am
I supposed to do exactly so I don't have
a lot of room to work with here it's
coming up fired dirt moving over there
I am the loudest handle jiggler in the
West where am I supposed to go I don't
know where he is
and frankly that's for the best Oh God
Oh God okay just closing
all right so i am i dumb Oh what am I
supposed to do it like I went to the
place that got unlocked from where he
was so what do i do what do i do the
thing in the clothes oh that door that's
the door that he busts open that's what
I didn't realize that there was an
actual door that he bossed through about
one of these paintings also has an
easter egg behind it but I'm not gonna
bother okay so I just can't charge I
can't make any noise I can't do nothing
compromise
my ideas stop saying things out loud
maybe you'll live long enough to find
out I'm going for it
this is the longest crawl I've ever made
I know there's tasty rats behind me you
don't need to go there great great great
great great good stuff good stuff good
stuff good stuff good stuff good stuff
oh my god let me in this room oh my god
oh my god oh my god I'm fine
you'll have no idea holding my breath
he's not behind me
he's definitely not behind me he is 100%
not crawling up right behind me because
I'm holding my breath and he's no way he
can hear me
what if I got what do we got here
nothing a whole lot of nothing are you
kidding me just a big bowl all right
what was even the point I can jump I can
leave my troubles behind great you just
keep doing that you seem to love it I
love it you know they're pests I don't
care if one of them might be a
world-class chef get him out here good
job are you okey no one's gonna say
you're a okey but no no please not like
this oh I am holding my breath you can't
get me
No
well I'm holding my breath I'm holding
my breath I'm holding my breath
[Applause]
why
well okay are you okay what just
happened what happened I don't
understand what happened I don't know
man I don't know okay so I just need to
get down that corridor again nothing I
need to concern myself with stop talking
you'll be fine he's killing rats over
there which is fine ooh that's an ideal
that is the opposite of ideal nothin ear
bub nothing here no don't come this way
no there's no need why would you come in
here there is no need yeah you get those
rats
name me no no no hi guy so I'm not like
I'm not invincible
when I hold my breath all right if I
keep my head on a swivel stay cool calm
and collected I should be having no
problems no problems a mouse can you you
need someone to open the door for you
oh he does hear that there's a crowbar
got a crew Bert
what do I do with it so I like that
they've removed all of the hidey holes
like that's good it's more just like you
got a tuck in a corner and kind of hope
and pray I thought I heard the music
rising up but apparently not it's just
the rain rain what's the problem nothing
no problems
I think I picked up at like a key and
that took the place of my crowbar and it
just dropped that's what I think abot
okay so I don't know what I'm gonna need
but apparently there are a lot of people
locked behind these doors I don't know
why the I awoke II would keep him alive
unless he was saving them for later
which is a delightful proposition who
are you oh my goodness you didn't tell
me this I you woke II was in our t'east
wow that's meaningful profound aha keep
these thoughts in your head unless they
are in your head which I'd say make your
head thoughts a little quieter because
they are real echoey thunderous even
okay so there's a door back here okay we
open baby Oh guitar don't mind if I
strum a few cards it seems like the
appropriate things dear I can get in you
kidding am I supposed to get that or
what okay we're cool it's all good
haunted guitar besides there was seems
to be no point to come in here so I will
mosey I'm gonna mosey right along just
moseying who another tape great
how about mr. Carlson's that I feel so
bad now everything makes sense that's
why they reached me
my children
I thought I heard footsteps I do hear
forceps thank God it doesn't say better
yeah I'd hate to have a flashlight in
the last like 12 hours versus one I
could recharge that only lasts two
minutes at the door at the end of this
I'm pretty sure it probably leads back
to the main area I don't know if these
key is gonna be important to it but here
I go I hear that that rumbly so am i
right by the red door well that's great
why did I do that why did I do that why
would I have done that why would I just
give the guy a path to me why would I do
that
for what reason now I guess I'd go back
and get the crowbar I'm glad I walk at
the same pace that I crawl okay I'm
assuming that I'm gonna use the crowbar
for some kind of board removal I doubt
that this is gonna be the thing that I'm
gonna use to bust open any doors I'm
just gonna take it to the first place
that I see with some kind of boards and
then I need a lever I forgot now there's
no way none of these are gonna be
triable
and monsters of Reps time I showed up I
mean stupid names rosette your name what
what who's Ryan I don't know what to do
with this River maybe the Attic maybe I
could reach it it's the only thing I
could think of
money no no
no no no no I don't know why I have to
jump up these but I'm up here now
great I've got a lever that I can use on
the power thing oh I don't know if he
can come up here I do not know that I
don't know
not scary you know what not scary you
think you can spook me with something
like that or shadow are you okey what
are you five nights at freddys with your
shadow Bonnie's and shadow Fred it done
no no it's gonna take a lot more
intricate things than that to scare me
I'm a pro how about how you doing can
you come up here please tell me you
cannot I would love it if you could not
do not
[Applause]
you suck you suck so much
you suck so hard okay I'm very close I
just got to go down I think it's either
one of these rooms on the right or the
left I don't remember which one
specifically
it's what everyone yeah it's this left
one okay I hope this doesn't create a
lot of noise I should have done this
before I
no no no not in here not in here not now
not yet oh my god not right now
Check Point oh my god
I got a checkpoint holy [ __ ] I got a
check boy I got a check for it my dudes
okay all right
oh if I got a checkpoint that means I
can pause for the moment oh what am I
seeing
generate secret URL address yes what the
Frick is this authorizing session token'
authorization complete encrypt a ssin
generating URL URL generated for what
what is that know so I guess I'm gonna
go to this thing oh my god it's a thing
why oh it's like an SCP thing I'm
ringing you oh my god there's articles
here what the [ __ ] Wow
alright um this is something to explore
Oh hate that oh yeah that's yeah you
oaky all right oh yes Anne are you okey
okay
I'm gonna save this for the next one I'm
gonna explore what those are and I'm
going to see what the deal is with this
site and then I'm gonna continue this
game because this game is interesting
and scary let's just see if I actually
saved my progress continue yes okay so
thank you everybody so much for watching
when I have more time on them pick this
up on a make more progress than I did in
this episode but let's see where this
game goes let's uh let's take it to the
end why not Owen played a good horror
game in a while that's I have some link
through it some girth some whoops paw so
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want to see more subscribe
ring the bell if you want to be known
when I if you want to know when if you
want to know the thing of when I put up
a video you can do that and check out
the other scary games that I played
through the drink Lincoln
scary game in description or over
suggested click them you could see them
there they're all good all scary very
good okay thank you
and
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]